in the heart of Los Angeles this is
screen junkies movie fights
and he signor today's episode is brought
to you by America's best unlimited
network don't miss a show with unlimited
data from t-mobile hello everybody
welcome to another episode of movie
fights live I'm so excited to be here
with some amazing fighters they's this
is gonna be a really fun show and some
fun topics today we'll be arguing what's
the worst movie of the summer of 2017
everyone online is already saying it's
the emoji movie we'll see if anyone here
agrees what two actors should star in a
face-off reboot oh that's fun I want to
know what you guys are gonna who would
you pick to faceoff in this day and age
and none of our honest trailer which
thank you guys for watching and since it
is ruining the clown industry forever
and that apparently not clowns in the
world I'm not happy because no one's
hiring birthday clowns now what other
occupation should get its own horror
movie lots of fun stuff so stay tuned
you can follow the conversation live on
twitter at hashtag movie fights live
let's see who our fighters are today
first right next to me he's a fighter
he's been on the show a lot so happy to
have I think his name is Dan Merle hi
okay welcome to show Dan Wow sorry I'm
we're never come back yeah and the
madman Merle is back here as back
starting on the ground up and you
excited to try and get that belt back
like myself up off the mat let's go this
is are you do you feel like you're
throwing off a bit being in that chair
alright interesting it's good that's the
fighters yeah he's on he already is not
in his chair like he has like oh yeah
alright well next up I'm so happy to
have our host of the wrestling podcast
tights and fights it's miss Daniel
Radford welcome back to yes so happy to
have you how you been I've been really
really good I have an apartment I have
AC I have this new wig everything's
great oh you're killing it loving it and
you're gonna kill it today and you've
got two strong fighters here I hope
you're not nervous I'm just gonna tell
jokes good okay you can win that way
Mike Mike Carlson has made a quite a far
movie fights career finally I'm so happy
to have writer for comics and for screen
mr. Marquez Rico welcome-back martyr to
beer it's been a while it has how are
you doing good good I saw you guys at
Comic Con but I don't remember the last
time I was up to here I didn't
I've ever fought Marc in a full-on fight
yeah we did the very first time maybe I
don't remember
all right let's pretend like you didn't
first time exactly
we'll help in since Dan is up here
fighting we need a fact checker of the
stars mr. lon Harris he's the man who
gets all these questions organized so it
makes sense that you're here helping to
fact-check this good show how long it's
gonna be a great show
in YouTube they are already saying the
emoji movies the worst movie guys why
are we even having this fight you're
wrong
well we will find out soon first up I
want to thank two guests on our fan cam
Will Robinson Smith and Isaac thanks for
coming guys Robinson I bet you haven't
heard that yeah where you guys from so
my brother Isaac lives here in the LA
area and I'm visiting him from Alabama
where I'm actually a television reporter
out there what's your beat so I'm a
morning reporter and I work for the ABC
station in Huntsville Alabama so just
below the Tennessee Alabama border line
awesome dude we're trying to get him
fired now well I'm gonna tell your test
will you report between segments for us
now to report on the right wing with
some social media reporting it yeah I
want to just cut to will on the con the
cam how is that round give me your year
reporting sky of the round and you're in
your local news station about your
experience here you never know shut up
should have planned ahead yeah next time
all right well I'm happy to have you
both thank you for coming there's gonna
be a lot of fun you guys know how to
play this game listen to your facts
creativity your arguments is what's
really important here so stay on to on
point let's do it
awesome live that montage still nice job
Harry that was great let's do a round
one guys
this came in from our Drago sixty six
what is the worst movie of the summer of
2017 man there were a lot of them to
pick and it's not just the emoji movie
let's see if someone did though pick
that dan what are you picking yeah I
don't think there were as many as there
were last year but the immersed movie
premise of 2017 then yes we would maybe
be talking about the emoji that was not
the worst movie this summer there were a
few that I juggled with but the one that
I settled on was Baywatch it was an
early May release and just as far as
just walking out of a movie deflated and
just disappointed and what I'd seen
nothing really top they watched you have
the rock who is I mean one of the last
few honest-to-god movie stars left and
maybe the last one that's gonna be
launched for a while
you have Zac Efron who's been found this
crazy weird second career in comedy and
has been in so many good comedies lately
you have a cheesy premise something
that's right for the picking I mean what
is easier to find comedic situations in
than Baywatch and this movie just
whipped it on every single level I mean
it is to painful hours I chuckled maybe
once or twice and I just came out of it
just it's just so discouraged just like
why you had everything going for you
it'd almost be hard not to screw up this
premise with this cast and yet they
somehow managed to do it and for me out
of all of the summer movie season is the
most deflating was big watch all right
let's hear from Danielle who is up next
what movie picking out of the worst
films of summer 27 um I went with
transformers 2 last night um transforms
last night is two and a half hours of
product placement and explosions which
is at least
one hour way too long you can be a bad
movie you don't get to be a bad movie
for three hours that's not fair
it's a Transformers movie with barely
any Optimus Prime which is what is even
the point
and the one of the biggest things is
that like these transformer movies are
kind of paint-by-numbers and
unfortunately what that means is that
like sometimes it kind of feels like
they just don't care they're gonna make
their money they know that they're going
to make their money and it's okay look I
think we've all had plenty of times when
we've called it inland and just kind of
faded till we made it at work one of the
places or sometimes in movie fights and
so that's fine you don't get to do that
for two and a half hours and for me
that's what the length of the amount of
time the complete incoherence of the
plot how incredibly loud and it's as a
Transformers movies of course there's
like little these weird jokes that don't
land and seem kind of like a little you
probably could have made a better choice
and so because of that I went with
transformers the last night all right
mark what are you pickin mine is was
hopefully the third in a trilogy of bad
reboots of this myth King Arthur then
The Legend of the sword I think is its
full title what a miserable miserable
miserable experience from war go if you
thought Charlie Hunnam stunk up Pacific
Rim
I don't think English is his first
language I think he speaks Klingon and
he's just doing it phonetically like
bola ghosty and Dracula this is the
third time we've had a King Arthur movie
since first night with Richard Gere and
Sean Connery remember that well yeah
they were King Arthur and name only then
we got Anton fook was mess of a King
Arthur movie where Guinevere was like
some Tarzan a savage leading a cult and
though the disaster and now we have this
King Arthur movie that was the first of
an ambitious seven movies well you ever
read a TV pilot they tell you don't save
stuff for the first episode because you
don't know if they're going to get
beyond the pilot this was saving all the
good stuff for later no Merlin did this
this table shows up at the end of it
Charlie Hunnam is doing Lock Stock and
Two Smoking Lance's it's it's totally a
mess it's every bad instinct Guy Ritchie
has ever had and
one talking about epically long movie I
think it might be as long as
transformers if I had cancer at six
months to live I would watch this every
day because it would feel like I live to
be a hundred at the same time just just
utterly you have the great source
material of King Arthur has Nolan
watched the John Boorman version there's
a lot of stuff to do there there's a lot
of fresh takes you've been doing this
this movie is easily by far maybe the
worst movie of the year so far all right
guys you got great opening arguments now
I've heard listen let me just say this
I believe all your movies are horrible
why is yours the worst fight it out
III disagree first of all there aren't a
lot of fresh takes left on King Arthur
it's been done so many times but on
televisions done in countless numbers of
movies miniseries I saw King Arthur and
I came out of it going like wow it
definitely wasn't good but I was like
it's it's it's interesting it's it's
it's really weird like it is it is like
a it's like a Guy Ritchie kaleidoscope
of just like storytelling it's like I
came out of it more intrigued than
hating it because it's it's guy Richie
style married to like epic fantasy
storytelling which don't seem like very
per year all footage from the Lord of
the Rings movies that he just stole
apparently it's a failure but this isn't
interesting I completely disagree I
didn't disagree and you know with you
remove these two movies with Baywatch
first of all what were you expecting if
you're going to McDonald's and it's not
good you weren't going to Spago it's a
Baywatch movie it's completely firm same
thing about 21 Jump Street Oh 21 Jump
Street what would you expect out of a 21
Jump Street movie and that movie was
great like there been so many good
r-rated comedies lately that yes I was
expecting a fresh take on this because
these takes have been done before and
with this cast I was expecting a funny
self-referential I'll say with with the
rock and Zac Efron I was expecting more
because they are both shown really
amazing communiques lately but when the
rest of the cast I don't know who any of
these people are and I wouldn't know of
them but they were sitting on that couch
right now you have to populate a cast
with good comic actors even the movies
of Zac Efron's that don't really succeed
Mike and Dave need wedding dates and
stuff like there's always interesting
cast members the rock and obviously the
movie Zac Effron and the rock thought
they were making because they apparently
thought they were making a much better
movie than this one and as far as
transformers goes
definitely what were you expecting how
many times you have to get food
poisoning before you stop going to the
same restaurant this movie at least your
movie had Merlin my King Arthur movie
takes a risk it might be something
that's a new King Arthur is established
but for Guy Ritchie to go so far out of
his wheelhouse
at least he takes a risk and maybe he
cares and I would much rather break
someone who was taking a risk and who
was going outside of what they normally
do I want to celebrate that and I want
to encourage it especially when we have
a summer that was so filled with
unnecessary sequels and also unnecessary
reboots and again this is a story that
we've told before but at least it was
something different and he was trying
don't know I tried on transformers III
competed I mean the guy rich he was
actually ever on set for this movie I
think he was watching it from his
trailer I this movie was rudderless I
thought it was just it was there was
there was no one captain if he's
watching it from his trailer then
everyone involved in transformers was
watching it from the moon nobody was
paying attention to this movie yeah the
Transformers like we got this question I
was already to like write down with an
asterisk transformers the last night
like I so was and and looking back on it
and I mean all you have to do to trigger
me is say age of extinction and I will
fly into a blind rage because I hate
that movie as much today as I hate it I
saw it's the fourth one I saw three
years ago the first Mark Wahlberg one
and looking back on this Transformers
movie I'm like it had all this they've
had product placement and had explosions
but it's for me it's more forgettable
than anything again these are all bad
movies so you don't think I'm not gonna
sit here and say that it's a good movie
but it was an inoffensive transformers
movie it was bad it had all the
landmarks of being bad but it I didn't
come out of it carrying anything that I
didn't carry into it with a weird way it
almost wasn't as horrible as I thought
that it might be which is the best
praise I'll ever give a Transformers
movie Baywatch is just there's nothing
worse than sitting through a comedy
that's not working at the very very very
least both of your movies have spectacle
they have something that can at least
engage you if only on a visual level and
Baywatch is just two hours in a comedy
that's not working feels like four hours
in an action movie that's not working
and I guess I do open mics enough that
I'm used to watching two hours of bad
but it's also you can you take the
marky-mark of it which is he his
character was awful in age of extinction
it's awful in this one at least with the
rock you have someone who's charming and
trying you think so but they not only
does he not charming in this movie they
take their biggest asset the rock they
take him out of the third act of the
movie almost completely he only shows up
to the end and so it's like you take not
only did they waste the assets that they
have they took their biggest asset out
of the last act of the movie is so you
don't even have that one thing but at
least your movie had glimmering moments
of charm of the rock and remaining to
you and glimmering moments of Zac Efron
in a speedo
I had Jude Law playing a gay stereotype
from 1925 Eric Bana being just there
like I need a paycheck I have a house
payment and Charlie Hunnam doing what
he's been done from the past ten movies
a minute just stinking the place up the
spectacle didn't cover up how lifeless
and just flat this movie was it just
felt like it was a rehearsal and a
rehearsal where everyone took cough
syrup before the rehearsal it was a
spectacle where everyone was just
brain-dead it was just lifeless and
there were at least chuck like don't get
here on Baywatch is an awful movie too
but at least drink Baywatch I laughed
two or three times okay can I can I hear
the positives in each other's movies you
gave me that but Danielle can can you
list a bit more positives in King Arthur
and Baywatch vs transformers 5 okay well
first of all the positives with Baywatch
are that I don't know necessarily that
the rock has been kind of since that big
Jehu spread came out on the rock which
was amazing and then Olson became the
rock for president I don't know that
Baywatch necessarily suffered from a
lack of rock I think we've actually
reached the tipping point on the rock
and I do think that it was positive that
they tried to subvert some tropes they
didn't necessarily work but again I
think that there is something to be said
for effort and I do feel like the jokes
weren't necessarily funny but I think
the people who wrote them kind of cared
same with King Arthur not a good movie
not a good movie but I do think the Guy
Ritchie kind of cared and also
bhana for getting a job for you in a big
movie being a movie star pan is mortgage
that's fantastic congratulations
alright Dan positive I would say that
for transformers as I said before it
does not be most offensive Transformers
movie which is a positive for me Anthony
Hopkins is doing something in that movie
that I found compelling at least I know
what the hell is going on that wasn't
like phoning it in like like tuturro was
in all those movies like he's doing
something crazy that's a given I'm like
doing this crazy thing so at least like
every ten minutes or so cut to another
Anthony Hopkins is I'm like okay I don't
know what he's doing but I'm gonna watch
what he's doing and it was kind of the
same thing with King Arthur was I think
that that's such a weird the alchemy
that it took to somehow get Guy Ritchie
and King Arthur on the same page like
whatever however they were actually on
the same page but however many projects
Warner Brothers merged to get them on
the same page like Arthur would be doing
like they go to these fight scenes it
wasn't like in a guy ritchie think i'm
like okay i did not expect this from a
king arthur movie and then he says this
kind of weird sensibility toward action
that again it's not a great movie but at
least left me going like well this is
different this is at least his take it's
weird it's nuts I don't know if I like
it but I'm compelled to watch it I would
watch you know I would leave that movie
on on TNT and the middle of the
afternoon it's an HBO Saturday you know
it's it's but it's mediocre it's mad but
it's not the worst movie great for
cleaning house cleaner it's a great
house stuff I've already gave you my
reasons why the Baywatch is at least M
is watchable and my reasons for the
Transformers will be being watchable is
it at least it embraces the King Arthur
legend you have Merlin in it there's
more identifiable King Arthur I got like
an ography in the first 10 minutes of
transformers than this movie if this
movie wasn't called King Arthur I might
have a different take on it but it takes
the name of King Arthur it's like I'm
going to Pizza Hut and they're giving me
sushi that's not what why is this called
people is called pizza and I want a
goddamn pizza this movie King Arthur it
just fails on every conceivable level
and the spectacle he's good at it but it
feels it feels cutting edge if it was
1996 using his final thoughts quickly
round up wrap up sorry to wrap up
Danielle final thoughts um so my final
thoughts are you did mention that
Anthony Hopkins was doing something
interesting and the interesting thing he
was doing was not reading the script
until right before this
started shooting even admitted he had no
idea what this entire movie was about
that's why I was interesting because he
was like I don't know why I'm here
someone drove me I went into my I went
to my trailer I hung out I drank some
water
I said some stuff and then I left which
I guess is interesting that's enough oh
my god yes just a day of drinks water
movies a search and he didn't he had no
idea they even said way in multiple
interviews he admitted that he had no
idea what this movie was about or why he
was there but he definitely knew to show
up and say some words all right Dan
yeah no Baywatch for me was just it's
not even that the jokes were cheap it's
that they even screw up the cheap jokes
like you know yes a boner joke is cheap
but sometimes a cheap boner joke can be
funny they even screwed up the boner
jokes in this movie like even the gimme
jokes that should be easy we're just
like overplayed stupid there's one where
he falls through a deckchair the
geography of it doesn't even work the
anatomy of it doesn't even work like
they can't even get the cheap jokes
right and it's just it's depressing it
like a bad comedy can be bad like epic
movie is awful to watch but it's even
worse if it's like epic movie or a bad
comedy starring actors that you actually
like because you feel bad for them and I
felt bad for every single person that
was in that movie cuz it just didn't
work alright lon Harris over there on
the boards people are I mean obviously
emoji movie
not even in the top 10 oh yeah they're
also calling up the mummy book of Henry
a lot of people's from when I spoke of
Henry didn't come up valerian snatch
Dark Tower and a lot of people asking if
we would have found it Netflix's Death
Note I feel like we would have if
somebody had asked that that's did again
every single one of those is better than
always I defend that in a way a lot of
fans were defending these three movies
even transformers we had a lot of
comments at defending it and the fans
really were expecting a trick question
we sort of tricked the fans by not
making this a trick question they're not
always trick question
well I got any report on that for that
round um well you know a lot of those
movies
I just gave a hard pass to I think I was
the same way yeah there were some gems
this summer which you guys talked about
last week some of the best movies of the
summer but as far as the arguments you
know I think marked me in a really good
point where you know you go into a King
Arthur movie and and you really need you
know the the mythos behind it and if
you're not gonna get that
then why label of a King Arthur movie
and you know for all the Guy Ritchie
isms that were in there
there was a lot yeah to save it but you
know all right at the same time you know
I think they made some good points about
you know you have all the that the rock
can bring to a movie and if you're not
gonna use it then you know that that's
kind of a waste of a gem you know for a
sarena a waste of a rock waste of rock
um all right thank you good thoughts
yeah this one's gently tough cuz you all
made fantastic arguments and you all
pick terrible movies how you knock the
other ones down and I thought mark
really did get some good night well yeah
well yeah it did I just didn't hear his
mate aired Mark's movie down as much as
the other ones were able to tear each
other down and Mark really laid out I
think something that there were some
chuckles even you admitted even the
awkward weirdness you're talking about
anthony hopkins mark sort of pointed out
it's kind of interesting
no one was able to make anything sound
interesting Arthur so I for that points
barely market the first point very first
round
I'm sure they said transformers on the
gum yeah they are not backing you on the
Internet
Twitter had transformers 51% Baywatch
30% King Arthur 19%
YouTube has transformers 39% Baywatch
34% King Arthur 26 all I gotta say is we
try to rewatch all three of those movies
more fun with the other two than king
are alright here we go question two this
is a fun one
none of our face off on his trailer
which was random but it's 20 years right
one two actors should star in a face-off
reboot so if we were to make face-off
today who would you put in there whose
faces are we facing off Danielle
starting with you
alright so I chose for this because I
think what are these central things
about face off is that you have to have
actors who are really willing to commit
and commit hard and people who we make
fun of face off but Nicolas Cage
did some acting in that movie and John
Travolta was also there and so you do
have to have two actors who are willing
to push it and who are willing to commit
so I chose Ryan Reynolds and the good
Hemsworth Chris Wow should showed some
shade there sorry but so
Miley's gonna have some we're talking to
you after this oh she's gonna have some
very polite I'm country now I don't
fight talking so I pick these two actors
because for one thing they obviously
like physically you don't have to do a
huge leap to believe that they each have
each other's bodies underneath they
might be the same person we don't know
no one's proven that they aren't yet and
because we have seen the range of both
of these actors you know we've seen the
range of both of these actors we know
that they can really push it hard and do
the comedy because face off genuinely
has some very delightful and funny manic
moments and both of these men can hit
those really funny manic moments but
they can also get do the really serious
boring John Travolta parts where you're
just like a sad dead whose kid is dead
so because of that I chose Ryan Reynolds
and Chris Hemsworth all right I liked it
mark who are you picking well I think
that's one of the better crazy
performances that that Nicolas Cage has
given he's given a lot of them and some
of the guns on ones are like like the
Bad Lieutenant or just unwatchable with
some of those like this are actually
really great and I went with two really
really great actors I went for a ton of
the upscale version this time with Tom
Hardy and Jake Gyllenhaal Wow
I think that both of them you talk about
gonna walk that - well you talk about
the commitment level of these actors
both everything these guys have ever
done from since their first performance
has been committing to a style and I
think that seeing Jake Gyllenhaal do Tom
Hardy and seeing Tom Hardy do Jake
Gyllenhaal because they're both their
physical tics are completely different
will be really fascinating and they're
both great actors - I mean if you've
seen if you saw his Tom Hardy's FX show
taboo and you saw a Nightcrawler they
both become amazing actors so to get to
see and they both in comedy they can
both do really great comedy so they
would get the lighter moments I think it
would be like a master class and acting
watching these two flip and it would
really elevate the genre alright Dan
yeah here's the thing
yours sounds very comedic and your
sounds very dramatic and I feel like you
both lost the core of what face off is
face off is a beautiful disaster and I
thought who could you swap faces forward
that would produce a glorious disaster
and that's why I chose the rock and Vin
Diesel to swap faces and in a remake of
face off there are so many reasons why
first of all they apparently hate each
other in real life which would just oh I
already love it
secondly I would love to see The Rock
trying to act like Vin Diesel but even
more so I need to see Vin Diesel trying
to act like the rock
because I don't know if he can do it
either way because either way it's going
to be incredible faceoff is not
remembered fondly because it's a great
movie
it's remembered fondly because it is
absolutely insane and these guys doing
this would be insane and this is why I
have chosen them as the two-face oft
actors Wow guys all right fight it out
well the biggest problem with yours
other than the fact those two actors
will never be on the same set ever again
is that van is 3 foot tall and the rock
is 6 foot 9 exactly you said you'd like
to try and see Vin Diesel act we have
yet to try and see Vin Diesel actually
try and act making my case for me mark
that's that that's that might be a
beautiful disaster but that's gonna be
insufferable after about 15 minutes
that's a great that's a great sketch or
a great Funny or Die yours is a little
lightweight I have yet to see Chris
Hemsworth give a performance that he can
play himself fully and let alone play
someone else and Ryan Reynolds is Ryan
Reynolds might is running the risk of
becoming Jim Carrey there's a good actor
in there but he's got his ticks that are
in everything now I never not never
don't I'm always watching Bryan Reynolds
in mine I think you have the best of
both worlds you have actors that can do
comedy you have actors that can do drama
you're vectors that could physically
mimic each other and you can this could
this could be like a good remake of a
bad movie the way that the way that the
Coen Brothers True Grit is a much better
movie than the original this could be
sort of a depart from the original
material make a good solid genre from
like a die hard quality genre film sees
it I every time you say that I just
think of Point Break and Total Recall
which are movies that tried to take a
corny original and do it in a serious
straightforward way I think might be a
drama but mine would be there would be
fun really cast two of the most dramatic
actors that there are really having
great community performance as many
times Tom what's Tom Hardy's great
comedic well I would say sane like the
he's a joke
and he is great and that this means more
movie although the ending with him and
Chris Pine this should be them getting
together not Reese Witherspoon but he's
actually got a deft comic touch and Jake
Gyllenhaal has in his whole career has
been doing community stuff I just think
this would be an interesting good movie
yeah I don't want a good face-off no
part of me that wants a good version of
that movie because I does sound really
dramatic but that's a different movie
like that's a criterion collection
version of face up and I don't know that
I want that and with the rock and VIN I
just you know how you talked about the
last round just feeling bad for the
actors I would feel too bad for Vin
Diesel because it would just be the rock
roasting him the entire movie and Vin
Diesel not being able to do anything
about it like when you put together like
two heavy plates and then like one dude
who's just kind of around I mean they
both are ethnically ambiguous so that's
something that that would have for then
but yeah I just don't want to that's yes
there that's our improv troupes name
actually I one of them diesels most
beloved characters only says three words
he's not gonna scream scream dude cannot
be he's not the best at the the did it
it whereas when you get together
Chris Hemsworth and Ryan Ryan Reynolds I
do agree that Ryan has tics but those
sticks are exploitable that's something
that happens worth will be able to do
and I think he would really throw
himself into that kind of comedy I would
like to see the slash fiction version of
that movie I mean I think the rocks head
is actually taller than Vin Diesel so
it'll be this little body running around
to the face of covering it or they have
to explain
which again would be amazing like again
we're talking about face offices to do
it like The Hobbit might even
miscarriage with a Gandalf so many great
pairing suggested by the Internet Matt
Damon Ben Affleck they want to see Tina
Fey Kristen Wiig do this there was he
Shia LaBeouf miles teller Blanchett
Charlize Theron we had a lot and then I
really like this one
Dylan McDermott and Dermott Mulroney who
had to write about it yeah alright look
I think I think there were three answers
here but there's one I think we do
really want to see and I think I will
say the internet was pretty overwhelming
I think it's not Marx because I do think
you took a little dramatic we don't I
agree with Danielle it's not the faceoff
we want so it came down to but
[Applause]
we're not giving up there but I could
just I just could feel you were with me
of like yeah we want to watch the
question is should start not will start
long with this hand overwhelming
agreement with you on YouTube
67% I want to see the rocket Vin Diesel
mix it up Hardy Gyllenhaal was in second
place with 21% only 11% want to see
Reynolds and M's burger on Twitter the
39% went rocky diesel 34% won Hardy and
Jonah was close 27% went Reynolds
Hemsworth alright great well here we go
round 3 this one comes in from the 14
kid in honor of Schwarzenegger upcoming
film by your friend Taryn yeah Gunther
killing Ellington hair out in October
I've seen about 30 minutes honey there's
something really funny um the stuff I've
seen Arnold has not been that relaxed in
the movies we're gonna talk about here
on screen he was a butter delight it's
really really a fun movie I'm excited
let's get him on a judge that's getting
the judge a movie film in the comedy
round that'd be amazing here we go but
mark your first the question is best
swartz Nagar comedy of all time I
actually watched a couple of these in
preparation we got the question and
unless you had a good time didn't you
yeah I did actually there's there's
actually a lot of these aged really well
couple really don't and one of them
we'll talk about in a minute Tommy I was
surprised to find that the one that I
had the most fun watching was
Kindergarten Cop because if you put that
in context when that came out
Schwarzenegger had just that was right
right after Terminator 2 I believe right
or was it before right before he was
known as this big action guy and to show
him exercise comic muscles and they say
you know but WC Fields famously said you
don't wanna work with kids or animals he
works so well with these kids I'm
surprised he didn't take that Eddie
Murphy route and try and make himself a
full-fledged family star because he's so
he's so delightful with these kids
because his broken English and he's
five-year-old kids who don't have a
bachelor Cabul Ares they're kind of on
the same playing field vocabulary wise
and it's just a delightful film and it's
a film that when he action happens they
don't try and soften the action and the
action is if you actually have stakes to
it so it's a it's a fun family film
when the bad guys show up Arnold's
really protecting these little kids and
you care about them and it's got a you
know it's one of his classic lines it's
not a tumor it's from that man that
scene still makes you laugh when the
little kid says it ham it's just a
really charming movie do I think it's a
great movie it's gonna save lives no but
it's a really fun way to spend 90
minutes Arnold Schwarzenegger and see
him exercising muscles that we should
see him to exercise more of Dan what are
you pickin my movie was the movie that I
suspect Mark was alluding to but we'll
see okay I actually picked last action
hero this was this movie I think is
remembered differently because of what
happened as it came out it was his first
movie after Terminator 2 it was the
Burger King movie had the Burger King
tie-in had the action figures very hype
it was very very hyped and people were
expecting a Schwarzenegger action movie
like that's what it was sold as and it
wasn't that that combined the fact that
it opened the week after Jurassic Park
and which ate up all of the money it's
kind of remembered as this misfire bad
bomb and it's really not that I think
that when people went in expecting an
action movie and got this kind of
meta-commentary on action movies they
they were a little didn't quite know
what to make of it and I think time has
actually treated this movie a lot better
because it's in a weird way it's kind of
a progenitor of things like honest
trailers and that it's stepping out of
the Convention and it's commenting on
all of these things the sergeant the
fact that everyone has followed there's
only if there's only a 6 million people
in LA how come everyone has a phone
number that starts with five five five
the idea of like you know the the stars
are are invincible and the co-stars
aren't I think that that stuff has
gotten better and it looks like you know
in the age of Deadpool and things when
moviegoers are used to being pulled out
of the action and kind of forced to look
at what they're watching and commenting
on it I think that it has improved with
time and it's able to do you know Shane
Black data passing the SEC 10 is done a
lot of writing on superhero movies wrote
this helped write the script it's the
kind of movie that can have a running
gag about a henchman with a glass
eyeball and an Ingmar Bergman 7th Seagal
joke into the same movie it's really
just kind of weird and unique and I just
think it was released in a bad
it was a different tone than what people
were looking for but I think it's gotten
better with time so that's why I chose
last action here Danielle what are you
pickin um I went with one of my favorite
movies of all time I'm choosing true
lies I loved True Lies it is a fantastic
movie the action is fantastic it makes
you not hate mr. Roseanne Barr which I
think this is the only movie where you
actually don't really hate that dude
it's summer whatever his name is um sexy
it's funny the action again the action
is also very very very very well done
the comedy moments are impeccable the
timing on that from you know there's
that moment of the sexy stripping and
then the moment where the gun falls down
the stairs there are fantastic moments
to this movie and it's one of those
movies where everyone I knew liked it
which made me initially be like oh it's
not really something I'm gonna be into
because you know and when you watch it
you go like this is better than everyone
said it was and it actually feels better
than it has any right to a movie about a
dude who's a spy who lies to his wife
who hangs out with Tom Arnold all day
and then she finds out and she becomes a
semi it sounds exhausting but every
single beat of this movie it's kind of
impeccable and bulletproof it's
incredibly it's funny you believe the
spy stuff you believe the moments where
it's like oh he's a spy but he's also
just like the spy world is weird and
kind of bureaucratic and it gave her -
war - [ __ ] a great chance to to be
funny and to be awesome but also the
chemistry between those two characters
was fantastic and I don't when you think
about swartz [ __ ] sexy isn't the word
that you use but in True Lies
Schwarzenegger was sexy
he was real sexy sorry I might let's
take the fight out I see mark about
Raiders yeah musician this was one of
the movies
tried to re-watch and I would say the
two of these three visors realized two
of these three movies are very much aged
very beautifully True Lies watch it now
that scene with Jamie Lee Curtis is so
misogynist and rapey and doesn't hold up
in today's day and age Arnold is
Arnold's very good in it Tom Marvel is
very good in it but the movie is really
really everything you think badly about
James Cameron's treatment of women in
one movie and kind of racist the
terrorists senator right out of like the
worst kind of you know Nazis sort of
like this is what people of color are
like if they don't even trying they're
not even interesting they're just
cardboard characters that felt like they
were out of a movie from the 30s and I
remember loving True Lies as a kid when
I saw it and the action sequences still
hold up
but the undertone of the relationship
between him and Jamie Lee Curtis is so
weirdly mentally abusive that I made it
through about 45 minutes of the movie I
was like I'm really this movie makes me
really uncomfortable I think the last
action hero isn't really a comedy I
think my action hero is an action comedy
I think and the problem with last action
hero which I would to argue with a lot
of movies that are ahead of their time
is that the audience just didn't get it
it was meta before meta even was a term
that existed I think it's a really
ambitious movie but I think it's comedy
with a lower case of C naught and then
it's an action movie first I just think
that of the three that this is the one
that even if it might be slight source
material is the one that is the most
enjoyable and the one that given the
three choices the one I put on to watch
yeah I mean I think laughs laughs and I
think that last action hero is a funny a
movie as Kindergarten Cop is my case
with with True Lies is number one I I'll
agree with mark to a point the the Gimli
cursed scene for me to kind of creeped
me out now it just it's it's wrong it's
just which it's weird particularly just
in the context of just with time I just
don't know how I don't think that scene
ages very well even if at all but it's
really hemming it's a joke but it's like
does it seem like she doesn't know what
to do it just feels it does feedback
that scene does stick out to me and also
I've always thought that there are some
great things in True Lies but I've
talked about fourth act like True Lies
is way too long like true lights ends
and then goes on for another 30 minutes
and that's always been something that to
me is just like it's just it's just it's
to me it's too long it takes a simple
premise and just extends it way past its
viewing point Kindergarten Cop
I agree has some funny moments but I
think
people talking about Kindergarten Cop
the movie they talk about the 30 minutes
at near the beginning where he's meeting
the kids and it's not a to move and all
that part but there's like the last half
of it is like there's them there's a
fair and there's a crisp Crispin there's
something there's like there's a really
bad criminal supply that's like that the
ending is kind of lackluster and and
like the first half of kindergarten cop
is better than the second half whereas I
think last section hero if you look at
it as a whole it is an action movie it
does have a lot of laughs it isn't
better you have Arnold playing Arnold
and kind of playing with his own image a
lot but also I think it's the more
complete movie it's a really fun movie
but it is kind of like the TV Tropes
calm the movie was before Joe because it
was before most calms and the problem
with True Lies for me watching that
movie
I think the point of it is that he's
such a bad husband and it's so
misogynistic though so much of that
movie is about Jamie Lee Curtis getting
agency and if you watch that movie her
that's not Cameron or the screen but it
still in there she's in the she's the
actor in there and performance has to
count it might not be the script for not
arguing best script we're arguing best
movie and her performance is definitely
part of the movie when I watch that
movie again I felt bad for her well no
and then I greet like you do feel bad
for her in the beginning like he is
awful he's a terrible husband the weird
thing where he's like show up and I'm
gonna rub a rose on your lips and like
pretend like she's gonna bang some dude
she doesn't know that is terrible but
throughout that movie you do watch her
become stronger she confronts him and it
by the end of it she has complete agency
she decides to stay with him which I
don't know I don't know that I would
have done that complete addiction well
that is complete agency because that's a
decision that you make if you're gonna
be you know I'm all about choose your
choice and that character decided that
her choice was going to be that like
being a spy is really fun and exciting
and so I'm gonna stay with my dude and
we're gonna be spies together that story
is the story of her character blossoming
from a woman who is mousy and being
emotionally abused in a lot of respects
to someone who's super badass and
suddenly a spider and stays with her
abuser voluntarily who can
you say over the course of the movie do
worse and worse things for it to her
it's and I guess I loved that movie when
I saw in the theater that movie is just
so hard to watch now it's like the James
Cameron's gone with the wind you're like
wait whoa what's happening in this movie
and I would argue that I think last
action here has a lot of admirable
pieces but where you say the first half
of Kindergarten Cop is good and it's
kind of it doesn't fall it falls apart
in the second half I would argue that
this is like a jello mold that never
sets there's just so many floating
pieces that it's like 12 or 13 different
movies and there's always lots of them
are really interesting but it never
feels like a full movie to me it feels
like they filmed the treatment and they
didn't know what sort of tone they were
going to commit to and then tonally of
the three I think this one this one is
the slightest of the three I'll admit
that but what wasn't what's the most
important comedy he ever made I think
this one if you showed it to three
people that had memories you shouldn't
the people have all three of these this
is the one that's gonna get the most
lash and people are gonna like the most
of you the most happy with so jingle all
the way the Internet is displeased also
a lot of people twins came up but a
junior came up a few times you revealed
a lot of people Batman and Robin also a
comic he's like community figure once
you've taken if you'd known it was
allowed maybe I don't know I'd have to
think about it Batman or Robin is one of
my favorite movements at that time and I
have gone I have talked about this just
open yourself up to a whole thing we got
this correct but Richard Tyson plays
Colin crisp senior Richard Tyson from
the famous sherilyn fenn softcore porn
movie - moon Joan correct watched a lot
in the summers and then I would add also
just a little trivia factoy the
glass-eyed villain in last actually or
not a lot of people never Stan's Tywin
Lannister
dance played that happy face in contact
exactly they go yeah this was a little
easier for me at least sick look it came
down to mark I think mark so let's load
up to me because I while you were like
out True Lies does go why on too long
all these movies have great parts to be
fair and especially when you watch them
in the day they were fantastic movies
but the half a good movie for
kindergarten cop was a little bit of a
stretch for me and then when you said
mark that uh it's so that last section
there's a lot of pieces and never full
movie you just really sort of spoke to
me clearly because I do remember the
ferret attacking the guy and like there
is a sort of an exciting scene at the
end where he's got to save the kid and
Chris shows up at the school like it's
room it's memorable they're gonna cops
famous ferret attacks I was shocked how
much I laughed during kindergarten but
then I'm less action ear I've seen them
both about the same time ago it's I do
have trouble remembering the full movie
like yes great parts but when you're you
made that argument if it's a fuller
movie I think that coupled with the fact
that realize whatever has some it does
have some issues of does it hold up at
the same but is it the best comedy best
action of these three hands down but I
think Kindergarten Cop wins for best
comedy market on YouTube they agree with
you pretty strongly 55 percent win
Kindergarten Cop 27 percent Last Action
Hero
16% realize a lot of people calling us
out they didn't necessarily think true
lies with this financial movie but on
Twitter or more though why would the
comedy you didn't even mention Bill
Paxton
he's so much better than material but
that's a Twitter true lies actually one
39% for true lies 35% Kindergarten Cop
only 26% for last action shocker
I agree the bum rap can you watch that
now Last Action Hero absolutely
contemporary last section here because
movies got a lot more meta in the time
since then yes I don't think you're in
directed that right yeah I don't think
he got it feels like overwhelmed by what
was going on after drastic park back
then it didn't work that way we know
it'll cost too much money to move the
date and idiots
the movie bombs cuz it just got soirée
question for this came in from Batman
xenomorph in honor of Labor Day this
weekend coming up what movie character
has the best job alright Dan we're back
to you you're up first what movie
character has the best job I went with
dr. Henry Jones chair Indiana Jones
most people say like oh he's an explorer
that's his job no that's that is not
technically his profession he is an
archaeologist more specifically he's an
archaeology professor and if you track
him throughout all of the movies he
works at a college called Marshall
College and this is the cushiest gig
ever he can leave literally at a
moment's notice no advance warning for
as long as he wants comes back still has
a job it's a state school the school has
a museum that subsidizes his adventures
he can bring back things that the school
museum will then buy from him to give
him extra money in in Crystal Skull
communist show up they chased him around
the campus his son drives a motorcycle
into the campus library the FBI raids
his office and the worst thing that
happens to them is he gets indefinite
leave with pay and then gets his job
back
this is the best job so that's why I
chose Indiana Jones alright Danielle
speaking of best jobs in the world which
people can just walk away from I went
with God and Bruce Almighty he was
obviously trying to teach this man a
very important lesson he also gets to go
on vacation so you're picking away
Morgan Freeman or Morgan's God no no not
Jim Carrey because Morgan Freeman also
was God gets to mess with people yeah
you just get to mess with folks all day
because you're like guy and you they
obviously like it's very much that
movies version of God but to be able to
step away from your work and just be
like you know what I'm going on vacation
you learn a lesson you go ahead and be
me for we know however long and then
I'll step back you know and and reclaim
it that's amazing especially being able
to have the powers of being omniscient
and then coming back in and because part
of it is yes he is teaching very
valuable lessons because that's kind of
God's deal but also like come on it's
really fun to mess with that dude right
waking is having them but like he's
having a really really really good time
messing with Bruce and I like this kind
of teacher trickster version of God who
also apparently gifts like 14 vacation
days all right mark who you pickin I
picked as a pet owner I picked dr.
Dolittle and no no no not the Eddie
Murphy one the original one the Rex
Harrison one because what would be more
awesome than being able to talk to
animals animals are cooler than most
people it's a great job you know can you
imagine anybody that a pet would love to
know what their animal was thinking I
would love to have the conversation with
someone that loves you unconditionally
like that I think it's a great job you'd
be helping people you'd be helping
animals I think we would treat animals
better I think it would make the world a
better place I went a little kind of
serious with this question because I was
like you know I love my dog so much I
was like I want to talk to my dog I want
to know what he's thinking I think that
would be a great power and I think will
be an awesome power and I think it would
actually help if their power exists and
you could actually help save species you
could say to people no pigs actually
can't think we shouldn't meet them
anymore and we would have it would
enlighten us on May and elevate the
society in the world so that's kind of
big broad glamorous strokes but that's
how I felt about this question all right
fight it out I know this could get very
interesting
let's talk to dr. Doc's God but you know
what God got his an absentee boss he
gives his job for two weeks - Jim
[ __ ] Kerry wasn't sitting back and
also paying attention Oh nonsense he's
on vacation and he still has to pay
attention yes so that's utterly
irresponsible he doesn't get a chance to
pay attention there God you pay
attention to everything right back I
know y'all I know y'all I was with y'all
at Comic Con we were on vacation but we
were also working you can mess with
anyone at comic-con and just like that's
my entire career oh my god and with with
yours you know you're very funny because
the direction you went with him being a
teacher and you know that would be if I
was like a conservative Republican I'd
say that's why teachers unions are bad
because he should have been fired but
you also said remember in a crystal
skull and be having the great pluses of
being a professor like that and having
to be in crystal skull that negates all
the good things about that job miss the
best part of the argument which is that
his son Rex the campus library and he
didn't get fired yes but he still have
to be in the movie Indiana Jones in the
Crystal Skull aliens it's not so bad for
Nina jill's is bad for us it was bad for
him he got to go on a crazy-ass day God
has seen aliens and when he's not that
he's not the teachers lounge making
coffee and giving his powers to some
crazy person like Jim Carrey yeah he's a
great boss he's a great thing you both
picked both big regressions that come as
an enormous amount of pressure God is
literally in charge of everything but he
can't because like it leads they can't
just leave cuz he's like you said he's
omniscient he can't go sit on a beach
cuz he's still aware there are no
burlier no noise cancelling headphones
when you're gone
and then imagine if you did ignore the
silent the pleas of every human voice
yeah you're right dr. Doolittle I mean
my god it's just non-stop every animal
man I'm sorry you're sorry Hannibal
that's hornier in pain it was not
psychic they have to talk to him it's
not like he's gone on mission hearing
all the voices he's not gonna hear about
her ex he's not gonna hear about dogs
having sex any more than you hear about
your neighbors having sex unless you
leave you know unless you're nearby or
you're the windows are open so that's
not the apartment mark okay I just think
that Indiana Jones I think if you
pitched his job as a professor I think
that's the great job all that other
stuff he has to do you say there's no
pressure
Indy the American government want you to
fight Nazis and fight the arca that find
the Ark of the Covenant in the midst of
the desert oh that sounds like a great
job I don't need to tell my boss and I
can be gone as long as I need to
he does have two jobs he does come with
two jobs yeah he is like every lyft
driver around here like yes they drive
forklift but they also have a secondary
job where they like write scripts or
whatever like people have two jobs you
can't both of them he actually can sell
the artifacts back to the school he
works for that's like poaching that's
cultural appropriation and stolen
artifacts just busted we just busted a
dive was it the Walton family or some
other family happy not me the Hobby
Lobby family for buying trafficking in
stolen artifacts that's an international
crime first of all so he's a bad teacher
international criminal and not really
good at a second job he's a great
teacher his students love him well that
girl does in that movie that movie we're
never gonna say exactly I'm just saying
he's a great teacher he seems to have a
very popular class it's always full of
students again he can go and do his
adventures whenever he wants it it's
kinda to have a job here classes for
students it's always an honor it's a
the worst case scenario of indiana
jones' job is someone gets to cover in
my class and I get to go have an
adventure and then the worst case sister
once our job is the world dies the worst
case scenario of yurikawa is i have to
listen to every duck this is what
animals are gonna say it's like four
things I'm hungry I'm horny pick me up
or let me go outside we'll just make a
new one doesn't answer
god I don't think he cares if you
believe in him or not because he's on
vacation he's gonna go on a beach and
he's gonna come back
what does God need suntan that makes no
Sun what was that that God doesn't need
a suntan I'm sorry no I just the
pressure that comes with being God is
not worth the perks if the only parties
that's trying to mess around with people
it's not worth being responsible to the
livelihood of billions and billions of
it's very responsible and yeah dr.
Doolittle again like is it is it you can
talk to the animals okay like fine you
still have to be a vet like you still
have to do the work it's just do you
have to talk to the patients you still
have to be a surgeon and save children
Oh God I'm just saying like there's
enough satisfaction to save the lives of
animals either way I don't want to hear
them say ouch when I give them their
rabies shots it's be nice to just save
they probably don't own a pet at the
moment do you I am an adoptive father to
two cats abundantly clear what
every hour you were a dog owner they
know I know exactly where I stand with
being a dog owner around dr. do it like
that
dr. Google around dogs would be the
worst because doctor one to a dog park
yeah dogs are like a media icon for
animals as soon as you walk up to any
dog or any animal especially once they
know that you can talk to them I do feel
like literally all they're gonna say all
day long is like oh my god help me oh my
god help me oh my god help me there's
the other there's the triste because you
said oh my god help me we said it was
the best job nothing he was good at it
but he's not doing it he's terrible just
ignore your job who you think you're
talking to you that that's good that was
pretty great but that's not the God
they're talking to you wow this is I
need help on this one lunch
well the Internet has a lot of
particularly upset a lot of people feel
like both God and Dolittle are those
powers or jobs like Jones in a way has
powers too because he gets going he's
missions like if you had dr. Dolittle's
job would you be able to just hear the
animals or is this job just treating the
animals so a lot of debate goes in the
home doctor around those also a lot of
people tried to choose picks that are
unemployed people like Jay Gatsby or the
tube-like they think they're being all
clever like I'm gonna pick you guy with
no job that would be the best job others
that came up James Bond Willy Wonka a
lot of people saying they thought Dan
was gonna pick Captain Kirk again the
pressure yeah it's a lot hard to be a
starship captain and then I was shocked
more than one person said captain
Phillips which is
every time I think of that moment with
Tom Hanks afterwards on the boat I think
the best acting he's ever done it's
amazing whatever that scene is yeah
my understanding is she's an actual EMT
so she just came in and did the job she
was doing for someone that was acting
like he was god it was easy to write him
already so oh my god
so good I mean anyway I just I think
about that blonde I need help on this
okay well yeah we thought from the from
from the gang there well I think they
they did a good job of knocking down God
it just seems like a lot of thought so
too but let me challenge you guys she
did make a point to cure some he's an
ass is he really is that version really
responsible that version of his job yes
just sort of leave and he's always happy
and doesn't be once true but then so
does Cindy you know just you know drop
his responsibilities I'm assuming
someone artifacts but I guess you who
cares that being a jerk it doesn't count
she's right though the dogs would bug
you all the damn time saying feed me
help me but then they bug God too but
this guy doesn't care but there's not
doing his job character go ahead lon
final hi yeah I actually thought I mean
I thought everybody made an intriguing
point it was sort of hard to figure out
you know like who - silent but I did
feel like we heard a lot better
arguments against both God and Dolittle
I didn't really hear a lot of very
negative in the points that survived
right and all the stuff that was
negative it just more he's a jerk or
driving things wrong so I'm sure your
argument even when he destroys the
library they they believe that's a
pretty damn good job all right Dan gets
the point but very close that was a
yeah the internet strongly felt they
went they lean very much towards Indiana
Jones 74% on YouTube 22% for God 2%
right now I'm gonna reload cuz that's
probably not right on Twitter it's 54%
Indy 34% God 12% doula that's because
none of them have seen it I think they
probably just assumed you met the Eddie
Murphy 7% for Doolittle there you go all
right let's do this
question 5 after it ruins clowns forever
which is gonna do because a lot of
clowns are upset but that was their
birthday
that was the news story is that birthday
clown bookings have dropped dramatically
before so they would cuz even the
parents are like no thanks I don't want
that here what other occupation should
get its own horror movie Danielle you're
up first
um I am choosing Vice Principals because
I think I think everyone the Vice
Principals assistant managers anyone who
is not at the top of the list they
always have that little bit of like a
dark spot they have a grudge they're
trying to make it and so wow the
principal gets to be your pal
the Vice Principal is usually the one
who ends up getting up in that ass and
so I think that they they have this
sense of authority they are someone that
children trust which is the same as like
a clown or anything else they've got
that trustworthiness or at least the
appearance where you should find them to
be trustworthy but there's something
dark inside every vice principal there's
something dark and lonely and way too
ambitious and I think that if you do
something that feels like you're gonna
mess up the vice principal's chances to
become a principal or to ascend they
will murder the crap out of you
all right that's why I'm going with Vice
Principal I am fascinated Marc this is a
I'm going with politicians I think
actually making them just Devils from
hell
is just the next logical step because
they control so much of our lives
already and they make decisions they
obviously much like your god don't care
about us
[Music]
not the God she believed about foods
here I just think the politicians the
next logical step because we're living
in a scary world right now the
politicians and if they all took off
their skin suits and turned out to be
demons from how I'd be like Oh duh yeah
I think I think and Vice Principals I
went with again that I think horror
comes in the to everyday things and so I
went with carnival ride operators
sometimes referred to as carnies I don't
know if that's offensive or not so I'm
just gonna say carnival right off the
carnies apologies the carnies if that is
a derogatory term I think that there's
like you know it's kind of like clowns
it's like 98% of them are just
good-natured people looking to get by on
their jobs but every once in a while
I'll see a carnival ride operator now
look in his eyes and I'll just see
something man
I don't know what it is but it's like
they're pulling that lever to send me
into the dark and I'm not sure if I'm
gonna come back out of the other side
and again it's it's finding a like Jaws
it's finding the fear in an everyday
situation that's gonna make you scared
of something that you enjoy and so I
think it might be fun to have like a
horror movie of like you know they run
like the tunnel of death but it's the
actual tunnel of death you know one of
those old carnival rides you can get a
crazy Walder Frey looking dude to play
the guy yeah I think so you go alright
alright guys we think well I think I
think that carnies are scary from the
very beginning I don't who's ever been
like a sympathetic romantic trail of
carnies on film I think they're always
ruined those are the people that I would
be afraid of offending by calling them
carnies and you said something about you
know the you're usually pals with your
principal and not close with your
vice-principal what school did you go to
um
one where I was I went one where I let
her didn't drama and in choir oh so you
were so we would have been friends but
we wouldn't have known the principal
very well yeah I mean I I just don't
think Vice Principals I think Vice
Principals are the opposite of scary I
think they're powerless people who have
hit a ceiling in their ambition
are just kind of sad I don't think I'm
never gonna be running in terror from a
serial to a serial killer of icebergs
you see what that's how they get you
because they have that like congenial
like that veneer of like continuum then
ji-hyo veneer of like I'm a business
person doing business things and I'm
just here to help the kids just like a
clown does and then you turn around and
all the sudden the next thing you know
staff staff staff steps to have your
vice-principal has died for Vice
Principals believed they had anemia or
radiation poisoning they didn't look at
their the energy but these are for
children anyway and carnies carnies are
also like they're they're creepy but I'm
not really scared of them because they
all weigh like 12 pounds and smoke like
pall malls and at the cigarettes well
they all look like they probably have a
lung Stage four lung cancer
politicians can actually do things they
have access to nuclear weapons they have
access to controlling our lives and if
they they would actually make the tunnel
of hell ride they would turn the world
into the tunnel of hell and are they
close to doing that I was just going for
like an everyday kind of terror the
person that goes into the thing in front
of you just hear screaming and then it's
just this this thing that looks in your
face it just like tear - that's the
voting the ballot box you don't have to
get these people we'll see I think that
like when it comes to carnies um sorry
yes it comes to carnival workers man
I've known we used to have people who
would work at our carnivals back when I
lived on base my sister wasn't one of
them they are too lazy to try to figure
out how to kill kids like maybe somebody
who actually like built the rides might
build a ride that was like spooky and
can kill you but your average carnie is
just trying to like find a place where
he can go vape except for old Joe but
he's just he pull his mask off when he's
not he's lying to the Scooby kids he's
not actually really a scary monster yeah
you just trying to get money money buy a
beer and Govinda
scares the [ __ ] out of them though hey
guess mark guys they don't need to they
don't need to like actually murder
murder you like decisions bad decisions
can murder us all that's what's scary
they're so black
they're so blase about it they don't
actually even they're even actually the
balls to actually stab people to death
which you know up close
who wants them stabbing look at these
look at the how many times can I do
stabbed I mean I just made these
politicians that have been scary in
movies you have Damien in the final
conflict is the American ambassador he
actually is the son of the devil doesn't
get scared that you have the dead zone
you have Martin Sheen playing Greg
Stillson who's absolutely terrifying
what you said that they're not actually
directly killing us that scares me more
ablaze a faceless killer kills me scares
me more than if I'm fighting you direct
because I think something like a house
of cards but that's Lake Lake you know
uh crazy like plotting and like behind
the scenes stuff
I want my killers to straight-up draw
some blood and I think once again you
come in for that parent-teacher
conference and you're like you know what
you were being unfair to my kids I'm
going to report you to the school board
oh my god my head is gone I can to a
political horror movie because I mean
[Laughter]
come ask you question if miss Cameron
gave you a cookie would you eat it again
she's very nice and that is how you
would have hella died cuz miss Cameron
could have poisoned all your cookies
because that is how they get you rights
principles are not to be trusted
alright well I heard enough
lots of suggest a great suggestion to
the Internet magicians mailmen uber
driver came up a lot a lot
by the tattoo artist was a really
interesting idea you know because a lot
of people live in that Horror Story
everyday and then a porn star came up a
whole bunch if you want to see the
points are also a lot of fans of a
little film 2003's the janitor which
introduced us to yes No Deal horror and
then a lot of people said the dentist
too but that is already a giggles right
I know
geometric suggested tax collectors and
even came up with a tagline he's not
just coming for your money tax collector
crows okay I got good thoughts yeah mark
I think we're already in that movie I
think we all don't want to see more of
that movie right now so it came down to
vice principals and carnies for me sorry
horrible licensed professionals I was
looking for your rebuttal against Vice
Principals but when Danielle dropped out
they're just too lazy to kill kids
they're just leave your place find a
place to vape it was hard to a hard to
beat that one and I want to see them
drop blood so I got to give Danielle
that point two point for you the lion
killer Juggalos
yeah they do say fans of Sam Twitter a
very very close between the top two on
Twitter 41% when politicians 38% went
carnival experts and the 21% said Vice
Principals over on YouTube 41% went for
masters of the carnival arts for
politicians and 25% for me let's do a
series called masters of carnage
president I yeah that's right yeah you
did fantastic laughs like crazy thank
you for doing that no that's like last
minute they were like you want to be on
with mark and a nose like you came in
strong now you get to help me decide the
winner here okay so pay attention to
help me with these arguments and that
please keep some notes I'm gonna come to
you to get your thoughts cuz I'll need
help
lawn and well on the couch Isaac pay
attention here we go
well I'm sorry speed round you know how
this works I'm gonna give you five more
questions five more points you guys are
now tied so this should be interesting
any questions before we begin
there's no trick question in this round
is there yeah it's too hard in honor of
the 40th anniversary of Close Encounters
what is the best movie about making
contact with aliens et a rival
alright a rival versus et we heard you
first mark so whenever you ready ET is a
classic that is that has earned its
reputation as being a classic it's a
movie about acceptance it's a movie
about finding someone we connect with
it's this little boy who doesn't have a
father and a split home and he finds a
connection with a foreign life-form it's
about it's about celebrating it's almost
a Roddenberry look at the future and
looking at alien races it's not they're
coming to destroy us they're coming to
steal us they're coming to eat our
brains it's a hopeful movie it takes dam
18th grade but it's very personal story
it's about one boys encounter with an
alien arrival and in its own way was I
think it's ordinarily hopeful because it
was hopeful for not just a future of
humanity but the future of intergalactic
life it was this the most realistic
thing like it's not just a cute alien
it's like if aliens came down how would
you communicate it's so fascinating to
just watch how do you develop a language
and make linguistics interesting the
arrival is a great movie up until the
final act where it suddenly becomes goes
from a Stanley Kubrick movie to trying
to be a Steven Spielberg movie and the
arrival takes tropes that we've seen
before in multiple movies the obelisks
the quiet aliens but what are they
saying I think et made the chirps I
think arrival transcends the tropes and
it actually shows what would it be like
to actually meet aliens it's not a
fanciful thing about this boy you're not
watching this kid you're putting
yourselves in that shoes to storm out
humanity not just one kid thoughts damn
why and you both hit on hope which was
amazing God and you both kind of hit on
that like Roddenberry like that you know
the idea of like how do we communicate
what we do et is a very personal story
with aliens which is why people love it
so much arrival is way more about
humanity I'm always gonna go with the
personal story I think that it was a
great point that you made but I think
that actually wound up helping him
because I feel like when you when you're
dealing with something as abstract as
the idea of other life in the universe
you need someone that you can that can
be your viewpoint when you're unraveling
all of this so I like to mark the point
for you - okay lon couch top
does that really like both yeah really
great rebuttals really even like cuz it
is the contact of aliens he did sort of
give us a good yeah yeah I you know I'm
tempted to say just because I thought
that the point about you know sort of
its shifting tones towards the end sort
of turning Kubrick at the last second I
feel like maybe I could give a slight
edge to ET Draco do you guys agree yeah
all right there you go markets the first
point but that thing about linguistics
is a great I was probably in there
toward Stan but I think it is the best
we've got contact with aliens yeah okay
here we go number two look out 10th time
here it's not over which franchise is in
better shape currently which franchise
is in better shape I'm gonna list two so
get ready transformers or pirates
pirates Transformers Pirates will be up
first when you're ready mark go ahead
pirates does have a growing tiresome
performance by Johnny Depp but pirates
always has a visual world that's new and
exciting and expands the world the
Transformers movies are more of the same
it's meatloaf again movie after movie
after movie with less interesting actors
and less interest and the same mediocre
director the Pirates movies are
entertainment and disposable but at
least they're ambitious on the level
that they are and the production design
role for that all five of those movies
is spectacular
damn Johnny Depp was phoning this
franchise end to movies ago he's not
engaging anymore he's not fun anymore
they're not even featuring him in the
movie plus Pirates ended with a nod to
the fact they're gonna go back to Davy
Jones I'm gonna go back to Bill Nye he
was gonna be complete retread which the
last week already was transformers is
actually setting up new things or
setting up Cybertron Michael Bay says
he's leaving you're gonna have a new
director you actually have a chance to
have an infusion of fresh talent into
this franchise the first tala with how
many times do we see cars transform and
fight each other in a city and be
unrecognizable and then we're getting a
bumblebee movie about it just feels like
running on empty there at least there
are least stories in the Pirates
universe that I would be interested in
seeing further but pirates is going back
to the same stories you've already seen
they made that abundantly clear this
last one was a retread of every plot
point from the last four movies
transformers if only is keeping the plot
moving by bringing in more elements from
the cartoons and there's more to go Hulu
on go to you this time first actually
dan won that won pretty handily really
really like the point yeah how it sort
of ends with the promise of we're gonna
bring in a lot of new stuff yeah do you
agree I agree I agree for all of those
reasons that it's being the same as like
there is they are constantly explaining
the Pirates universe but now with the
idea that like we're gonna bring in a
new director maybe some nothing else
maybe that gives it a shot in the arm
but it might need yeah Bravo all right
do you got it dan can I pull it back
yes gonna disagree all right number
three in honor of Vince Vaughn's total
makeover for bra and the cell block 99
what's the best movie best movie
featuring Vince Vaughn's lost world it's
a low hanging fruit that's Vince Vaughn
people dodgeball Wow all right we got
the posture of your first in since you
spoke first mark well you sit over stuff
you said this is a movie with Vince
Vaughn not a Vince Vaughn movie lost
world is not a great sequel but there
are moments in it that are classic the
thing over the cliff there's all the
great stuff with the dinosaurs running
through San Diego bringing the lost
world into the real world there are
moments in that movie that are deeply
entertaining and there's buried there's
not enough Vince Vaughn to ruin it which
he does with all he missed it nonsense
and every smug thing he does in every
other movie so he's a supporting
character in this you have the lost
world also known as Steven Spielberg
presents people looking placidly at
dinosaurs the lost world took every bit
of magic away from Jurassic Park and
turned into a run of the mill sequel
that San Diego thing was terrible
it was the most uninspired piece of anti
Godzilla filmmaking ever dodgeball is
one of the most underrated comedies of
its era it's not spoken of in the same
words as old school and wedding crashes
and all those other ones by the way
Vince Vaughn also in those two good
choices spike
I think you just put the bullet in your
own mouth thereby citing two other
movies that are eminently more watchable
and more driven by Vince Vaughn and the
question here was what is the the best
movie with Vince Vaughn not what is the
best Vince Vaughn movie and for me less
is more with Vince Vaughn dodgeball was
the clever side of those three that's
what I said it wasn't spoken with those
but it should be lost world is
uninspired it didn't get people excited
about that franchise dodge ball has
hilarious performances from not just
Vince Vaughn but Ben Stiller from alan
tudyk Danielle or up to you that is
tough
wow that's really really tough really it
was easy for me I think I think I gotta
go with dodgeball yeah that's what
that's right was that two memorable
parts mark listed weren't as memorable
for me were they memorable for you no
well I do appreciate that you almost won
what the anti-choice are saying I'm
gonna pick something where he's super
not in it um this was it wasn't Vince
Vaughn vehicle it is a probably miss
best movie his best comedy wedding
crashers is pretty fun don't do as much
for me as and I am that might be the
Alec to mix of it maybe swingers and
made swingers and managers but out of
the two choices that were picked I think
dodgeball clearly took it I hate that
San Diego thing in Los world as soon as
Marty mentioned that I was like I'm
askin I did - all right number four here
we go what movie would be improved if
you added the Muppets are we getting
choices or no just no oh the Silence of
the Lambs
the fate of the Furious okay I love both
these things okay whenever you're ready
mark Kermit as dr. Lecter
Miss Piggy is clarice starling gonzo as
Buffalo Bill I apologize if you don't
have a time delay really Suarez I didn't
know that was you just wipe the slate
clean I can't wait for the gifs for this
one I just think it's ridiculous that we
have Miss Piggy fighting with Michelle
Rodriguez again I might get a little
more interested in those movies if you
added the Muppets the first the Furious
movie is already a Muppet movie those
aren't real actors those are suggestions
of actors and I firmly believe that
there are people with their hands up
them making them speak this movie would
be a really weird dark comedy like meet
the Feebles or something like crazy part
there's no scenario or what you just
posited and proves the Silence of the
Lambs it's an amazing movie you've
ruined it and you can't make best if
your is any more ridiculous by adding
the Muppets they may have been there I
just didn't notice Wow there we go
Danielle one of chimed in holy crap I
have a butt ha ha
I have to go send the limbs if only if
only for the line of fast-fading the
Furious they may already be pups they're
not actors they're the impression anyway
that's only for the table I would go
like animals Buffalo Bill not John's oh
wow I mean it's hard because it's like a
obviously comic pitch versus actually
answering the question but it is movie
fight so I think you gotta go with
actually answering the question so fate
of the Furious I answered the question
seriously do you
the question was what movie would be
improved if you've had it tomorrow I
think it would be insane
it would be insane would be insane I
don't know if it'll improve it though I
would watch it but I think Dan's right
he would ruin a classic film I gotta
give Dan the final point that puts him
over the end it's over Danny one
[Applause]
the sentence felt like you were getting
a little worried
that was a movie in a few ways their
mark and Draco you came and played
anything you'd like to plug all right no
fantastic job love is love Brazil going
to Brazil in December for the Brazil
version of it the German versions coming
out in September
I believe the Spanish version is coming
out in November and October 4th
I'm co-writing with Paul Dini the
creator of Harley Quinn we're doing
Harley Harley Quinn in poison ivy meet
Betty and Veronica that's great
Congrats love it Danny Adam Yale Radford
thank you so much for coming back you
were hilarious as always you're welcome
anytime you want anything you'd like to
plug um yes I've got my podcast tights
insights that comes out every Thursday
where I talk about wrestling also on
Wednesdays I do a live streaming show on
Wednesday nights on hyper RPG it's a
twist show where we it's in Cannon
superhero role-playing show it's in the
valiant universe my character might be
in a comic book which is real weird it's
just a bunch of comedians and the voice
of lucio from from overwatch and it's
super fun and that is on Pacific
Standard Time seven o'clock Wednesday's
love it killing it good work and thank
you for coming and finally Dan Morelle
you did it your back is fun it was just
like fight yow again you're gonna have
to keep doing this cuz you got to earn
that fight back with Spencer great I'm
ready and willing anytime anywhere next
week's gonna be a great fight we have
mr. Sunday movies flying in all the way
from Down Under to come fight here I
don't know if we're gonna see his face
usually only
see but stay tuned I'm excited to have
them back I have him here for the first
time live in studio that's gonna be
crazy he's flying up yeah I mean I think
most up to you but that's weird to have
mean we're big fans and that'll be a lot
of fun law and Harris Bravo over there
thank you anything to just tad follow me
on Twitter at L ons that one's will and
Isaac thank you guys for coming to have
fun oh we had a great time any final
report there first on the show how would
you how would you sum it up if we were
on your network oh well it got a little
r-rated toward the end of the show so he
might have lost the family viewership
yeah but overall really entertaining and
a lot of fun to watch in person yeah
some of it well some glad you guys had
fun thank you for the support and coming
I'm glad we could have you here and
thank you all for watching at home it's
always a blast a nice ignore on Twitter
and we'll see you next week mr. so many
movies and some other fun guests have a
great one bye-bye bye thanks again to
t-mobile for sponsoring today's episode
check out what makes them America's best
unlimited network at t-mobile comm slash
coverage
[Music]
you